get one bitcoin or debut for any sports  franchise you choose i'm taking the  second one because you can never take  that away from me i feel like bitcoin is  gonna evaporate and i would debut for  the buffalo bills and i would just i  don't even care if i don't touch the  field i would just be happy to put on  the uniform put on the helmet and go do  it bitcoin is not even i don't even know  how to real money yet i'm just learning  and i'm just figuring that out i'm  scared of the metaverse too they're  gonna start making real estate in the  metaverse and i'm just like getting a  lease in real life now so i'm [ __ ] i  don't want this bitcoin [ __ ] i'm going  to lose all of it give me the sports  franchise